Welcome back everyone it's charlie this is going
to be my new green lantern video for the new hbo
series as well as the new green lantern corps
movies that they're working on there was a big
comic con event from the past week where one of
the producers one of the arrowverse people who's
working on the shows explained a whole bunch of
details and talked about what's going on with
the series so we'll break it all down if you're
brand new to the channel be sure to subscribe to
get all the videos we'll do a new amazon giveaway
all you have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and let me know which stories you want them to
do during season 1 of the series so if it wasn't
clear a lot of the arrowverse people are actually
working on the green lantern hbo show initially
everyone just kind of assumed that meant that
there might be some tangential connection to
the arrowverse there was a big green lantern post
credit scene during crisis on infinite earths but
when they announced the roster of green lanterns
that they're going to do during season one they
raised a lot of questions about how they were
going to introduce this and what's going on with
the green lantern corps movie that they're also
still doing on the side with a different group of
people so the green lanterns that they announced
are going to be main characters during season
one these won't be all the green lanterns
that they're doing just the ones that the
story will focus on will be sinestro guy gardner
alan scott jessica cruz simon bass and kilabog
they did say that they would be introducing new
green lanterns over the course of the series so
because there are so many different green lanterns
just showing up as big characters in season one
that means that we'll also probably see owa
with the thousands and thousands of other green
lanterns from around the universe it's just that
you imagine those crowd shots and it's like how
many of those are actually going to get a bunch
of scenes and episodes probably not that many
we'll probably just see a bunch of background
shots they are working with a giant film budget
and it's going to be 10 episodes so that we'll
actually have the money to do all that but i
did a video a little while ago talking about the
roster and most people were just surprised to hear
that they're not supposedly doing hal jordan and
jon stewart as big characters during season one
mostly because they're reserving those characters
for the green lantern corps movie that's coming up
there's no release date for that movie yet but
if you haven't heard about the movie in a while
the pitch hasn't changed in the last couple of
years it's basically being pitched as lethal
weapon in space with an older hal jordan mentoring
a younger jon stewart which is where all the john
david washington john stewart talk has been coming
from because he would be a badass version of jon
stewart in the dc universe we just gotta find
who our new version of how jordan's going to be
please don't make the super suit green or
animated but the whole thing is the green lantern
hbo series is going to be filming next year 2022
release date so we'll see that long before we ever
see the green lantern core movie and based on the
roster that they announced especially the newer
green lanterns like jessica cruz and simon bass
you can't really do them without explaining what's
going on with hal jordan and jon stewart because
they were green lanterns long before the newest
green lanterns were minted also on the side of all
this everyone asking about diggle green lantern as
the aero series finale so we're still wondering
when they're going to follow up with that
mark guggenheim one of the creators of arrow was
doing this panel explaining the green lantern
core series because he's one of the writers and
the producers of the hbo series so that's where
a lot of people were wondering where diggle
would show up in the series because if he ran
arrow and he was responsible for that diggle green
lantern scene and now he's doing the green lantern
series why wouldn't he just carry his character
over well during the special comic con event he
actually revealed that he had stepped away left
the arrowverse to go work on the green lantern hbo
series meaning that the hbo series has nothing to
do with the arrowverse the way he explained it he
said i've left the arrowverse but i'm still in the
dc universe that was just his way of describing
the continuity so it doesn't mean never say never
diggle showing up on the series but it did cause
me to recalibrate my expectations for how they're
going to pay off the diggle green lantern moment
from the arrow finale so now probably what'll
wind up happening is they'll just do that on
the superman tv series because he's moving to
metropolis superman metropolis even though the
tv series is going to take place in smallville the
superman tv show that they're doing is going to be
released next year is basically a successor series
to smallville so everybody remembers tom welling
he showed up during crisis on infinite
earths i can do that with one bare hand
hello hi you are clark kent right can i
help you he's still alive out there in the
smallville universe so he could always come
back and cameo on the new superman tv series
it's just that the superman series takes place
on earth prime with tyler heckland's superman
so he's on the same earth as the grant gustin
flash and all the other arrowverse characters
that was the whole point of crisis in rebooting
the universe is putting all the arrowverse
characters on the same earth with a few exceptions
because star girl is technically a cw show now but
she's over in earth too he did say the green
lantern hbo series could run as many as 10
seasons so that would get you past blackest night
brightest day so for those of you that are hoping
that they would work up to a big event like that
it sounds like eventually they could get there
between the movies and the tv shows but like i
said it seems like how jordan and jon stewart
whoever they wind up casting for those characters
won't debut till the green lantern corps movie
also trying to get seven to ten seasons out of a
tv series is why you would introduce so many main
characters during season one so that's why they
have such an ensemble cast when they announce
the roster of green lanterns also deep cut too
everyone will remember that one of the hallmarks
of the way they told stories on arrow was their
use of liberal flashbacks there were flashbacks
all over the place in that series they announced
alan scott he's one of the oldest green lanterns
technically the golden age green lantern so for
some of these green lanterns especially sinestro
for instance who has a crazy story arc starts out
as one of the greatest green lanterns of all time
but then becomes one of the greatest villains of
the green lantern corps by the end of his story
we'll probably see a bunch of flashbacks for some
of the different episodes but they haven't really
explained how they're going to weave together
the stories of all these different green lanterns
but one of the reasons why they would do jessica
cruz and simon bass together for instance is
because they are partners in the comics the same
way that hal jordan partnered up with jon stewart
most of you know all about alan scott i've talked
about him in a lot of my justice society videos
he's also a character on the star girl tv series
but that's happening in a different earth i'm
assuming that now because marguerite is basically
saying that the green lantern hbo series won't be
directly connected to the arrowverse that their
version of alan scott will also be different from
the other versions that we've seen before no i
don't think that they're talking to ryan reynolds
about returning his green lantern there were all
these crazy rumors and they were just rumors about
ryan reynolds coming back in the justice league
snyder cut is hal jordan ryan reynolds himself was
making jokes about it on his twitter account and
if he's doing that that means it's probably not
happening right after they announced the justice
league snyder cut he released what he was calling
the ryan reynolds cut of green lantern with
a bunch of deadpool footage photoshopped in
and him photoshopping himself into the ending
of the justice league movie as a snyder cut joke
and on top of that he also did a deep fake of tom
cruise's face on his face in the green lantern
movie just because of the long time tom cruise
green lantern hal jordan rumors there will be a
lot of green lantern stuff happening in the snyder
cut next year i've already done a video about how
they're bringing the joker into that movie
jared leto's joker will be in the snyder cut
he was never meant to be in zack snyder's original
version of justice league so whatever you thought
the snyder cut was going to be it's going to be
so much bigger and that it just includes a bunch
of other side characters and side plots with zack
snyder paying off things that he would have paid
off in future movies that aren't going to be
happening now but bringing back around a green
lantern originally the plan for the snyder cut in
their green lanterns is that you have the green
lanterns in the flashback with the dark side
war but then you also have the green lantern
post credit scene that was reported for the movie
originally what he had planned to do when he was
still doing two justice league movies is that at
the end of the first justice league post-credits
scene he was going to have kiliwog and tomorrow
ray show up from owa to talk to batman about the
threat of darkseid and that was going to let you
know that the green lantern corps was going to get
heavily involved in justice league 2. then we meet
hal jordan and remember the slogan unite the 7
that they started teasing out when we got batman v
superman and they introduced the aquaman character
well unite the seven means unite the seven members
of the justice league so by the end of justice
league two hal jordan would have been that seventh
member so his version of hal jordan that he would
have cast for justice league would have then
gone on to the green lantern corps spin-off movie
that they had originally planned to come out get
this in 2020 if dc's original schedule for movie
releases a long time ago that they announced had
stuck we would have seen the green lantern core
movie earlier this year they just shot a bunch of
additional footage for that ben affleck came back
as batman to film new scenes they brought wonder
woman back at a couple of the other justice league
characters in addition to the joker like i said
so i think it's fair to assume that they're also
probably adding in a bunch of extra green lantern
stuff not just the original post credit scene that
he had planned but maybe even more than that going
way beyond but if we do wind up seeing how jordan
green lantern in the justice league snyder cut my
assumption is is that it will just be the snyder
verse green lantern and when they do the green
lantern corps movie in a couple years whenever
that does come out it'll be a totally different
version of hal jordan that they'll recast
there'll be a bunch more news about all these big
dc hbo series before the end of the year so when
they start casting some of these roles i'll do
more videos but leave all your requests in the
comments below and of course i will do episode
videos for all these big series when they come
the next big thing that's coming up next week
is the mandalorian season 2 i'll be doing videos
for all the episodes so make sure you have
alerts enabled for my channel so you don't
miss any of those videos we'll get the avengers
Wandavision episodes on disney plus after those
are all done too so one division before the end
of the year as well while you wait for everything
click here for the brand new marvel shang chi
first look teaser and click here for all the
brand new dc movie trailers the batman justice
league snyder cut the flash movie black adam
all of them thank you so much for watching
everyone stay safe i'll see you guys tonight!